you gotta follow Gary Vee not to become
wealthy not to become successful to
figure out how to live your life can I
jump in right now you just something
just happened that I'm like obsessed
with not to be wealthy check fully agree
not to be successful that one is
probably going to be my next 50 years if
we can somehow and you said it if we can
somehow redefine success in popular
culture we will change this [__]
world
well what killed me because right like
you said I know you agree with me and I
think words matter back to eloquence and
like semantics if we can redefine
success to waking up and being calm do
you know how many people wake up or
happy excited happy joyful calm like
like man if I could just eliminate the
anxiety of the world around dumb [__]
the [__] that people are anxious about
but not only anxious about unhappy about
you you know when when in in traditional
radio which barely exists anymore yes
the term we we're doing it right now
it's just called it's new yeah but hump
day yes you know that term of course
wnes hump day is Wednesday which is
halfway through the [__] you don't want
to do you get to the weekend just so you
don't have to do the [__] you don't want
to do one of one of my most successful
posts in the history of my 15-year
content career was if you live for the
weekends your [__] is broken right and I
because school was a disaster for me and
when I tell you Friday was do you know I
should have been a weatherman Howe why
when I tell you that when there was a
potential snow day yeah I turned into
literally a scientist I would I knew
everything I mean I the Doppler radar
was the most I probably had a poster of
the Doppler radar in my high school like
I disliked school so much that I would
live for Friday at 3 p.m. lived for it
lived for it and that was fine and I
understood that and then somewhere in my
30s when this all started happening I
was like wait a minute because then I
went into my happy Zone a grown-up and
lived right I was like wait a minute
this is how most people live their life
this is not sustainable I knew I was
getting out at some point this is what
people were doing for 50 years and that
got me passionate and that's why I talk
about what I talk about but even is it a
isn't it is it a problem with people and
individuals or our society and
businesses and culture and the way that
corporations and work maybe the older
generation look at the way you're
supposed to number one your point is
amazing and I know where you're going
and I'm a buyer yeah I'm just obsessed
with human
accountability it's so hard though for
the younger generation to go in there
and be like I want to Value everything
is hard yeah it's supposed to be life is
like I no I love where this is a very
interesting topic because I I'm a buyer
I look I love America I'm a I'm an
entrepreneur I love capitalism but when
things go too far it's not good like to
your point popular culture of what's
good and what's successful like I'm I'm
like such a buyer of like what do we put
out in culture right but I also think it
goes both ways let me explain so where
you're going I'm such a buyer of if it's
pounded in our face constantly this is
what success looks like it's hard on the
flip side we do things like give eighth
place trophies to kids now cuz we we
think that's the right thing to do like
we're always as a society going to get
into places where we go too far left too
far right which is why the first part
matters which is if you don't have the
capacity to be humanly um accountable to
you here's a good example back to
fatherhood and kids your your parents
told you things the world told you
things there are things that you decided
to do differently
right the end so just because the
world's telling you a [__] Gucci belt
is the right thing well I'm telling you
it's not so who you going to listen to
this person or that person there is
always a counter voice and a lot of
counter voices there's unlimited people
that tell you money's
horrible well and corporations are
horrible to me this but this is an
important point I I think this is very
big because I don't think the there's
right I think there's right for you and
the more that we give the power away and
blame parents corporations social media
this that and the other thing the
further we're getting away from the
truth which is we're capable I believe
I'm more talking you just you just hit
it though that's my problem my problem
is you have to know that you are
responsible listen as somebody who's
really deep into mental health yes um
you are responsible for your own
well-being you really are nobody else is
you're responsible for your own
happiness if somebody else is making you
unhappy that's just how you are reacting
that person you can't change that person
you can only change how you react to
that person and all the divisiveness
that we have in our world now
politically and socially is because
people go well we hate them you know
what they're doing this is why I can't
afford this is why I'm not up there this
is why I'm not happy and that doesn't
take away systematic truths like well
when you go off the gold standard when
there's a bigger separation of wealth
like I'm I'm not an absolutist I'm very
purple when it comes to a lot of these
conversations I don't find myself very
red or blue no either do I but and so to
your point I believe in everything you
said comma there's also other macro
circumstances right like there's a
million things that go on in life here's
my thing though the second you decide
that you can't it's over that's my
point